[Music]
and happening tomorrow a big celebration
at one of the oldest downtown properties
binion's gambling hall can you guess
it's been around for 70 years manager
tim lager says the property has worked
hard to maintain its brand over the last
many decades trying to stay loyal to
founder benny binion's philosophy but if
you have good food good whiskey and good
gambling people are going to keep coming
back
you can't fake quality and that's how we
feel when you have a drink with us it's
a quality drink it's it's not overpriced
but also it's a fair drink and i think
and that's important same thing with the
gamble we want to make sure somebody
comes in here and when they play our
slot machines or our table games they
have good odds and they can enjoy
themselves
and stay with us for a long period of
time
that's how you stay vintage vegas
there's a lot of first opinions if you
want to learn more you can head downtown
this weekend for gaming and food
specials to celebrate the big milestone
70 years with a good whiskey apparently
good food and good whiskey denise
because no wild night or great story
ever begins with a salad
correct 100 it doesn't happen